[Music]  rob would've loved this place  he's a good man the best of us you know  they have walking trails in England pubs  come on where's your soul look we go  Southwest through here  we caught the journey in half what's  through the forest yeah why not should  have gone to Vegas  are you the foul Savannah fall over in  Vegas to me now is it me what is it  really quiet in here it's been gutted  could we hunt as our bait possibly or  it's the bit they don't show you in the  nature documentaries a warning we  shouldn't be here whether we to beach  the tents it's a ridiculous man won't  you think so either  don't in here anything come on  [Music]  so we're gonna talk about then oh no it  was a nightmare Phil all happened to you  them got spooked and we have bad dreams  alright nothing has done that to you  you've done it to yourself if you have  to deny everything because I do not  value your judgment we need to be  working together man  Oh  what the [ __ ] is that  [Applause]  [Music]